welcome to this video blocks fret yeah
okay ah the good old Budapest OIC even
playing the fire Rohit's with 94 no he
isn't okay i play this line against the
budapest with nijah for that's it's not
the best line ever but it has one
advantage it's nice it's easy to play
and still leads to kind of a slight edge
for wide
so well b3 is blundering stuff so maybe
protect the c3 night that's a might
prepare look at you one let's go here
yeah I can just play Bishop b2 next we
should f5 I can go if all I don't mind
that very much the big problem in this
kind of structure is that that I always
have a 95 in some in some shape or form
and this night is just annoying to face
with black it always looks at porn
snacks e7 and squares and you sometimes
really have a hard time to avoid the
move c6 but when you place is six well
then you d six bond is weak and it's
kind of a yeah a selection or you have a
choice between various evils yeah the
knight on d5 or the threat of the night
coming to d5 or the week pawn and quite
often black doesn't find a satisfactory
um satisfying answer to that okay I'm
trying for the a3 before plan trying to
be quick we should be seven this kind of
I don't know what to do move the only
thing that it does is after be four
takes takes allows night a 40 wow that's
ambitious so night to age five probably
I can go to d file of course but c6
looks like it doesn't have any squares
night eh five is good down and and watch
now his idea might be to play a four
alright I'm going for this or before
it's also good right before and then c 5
mm that's all good this is another band
move down I'm looking at the f4 square
so f4 is not easily playable yes this
sensor some D porn into into problems
but ok let's see what happens maybe he
just wants to push a forint or hell
breaks loose you never know what the
intention is let's see there um be 45 i
also have f form but this is a very m a
tough decision
hmm i don't know if i should go out for
him candidates let's prepare let's
prepare that and also make sure that FY
is not hitting at least not easily okay
and can I go F for not true
45 I don't know night f4 looks like very
very decentralizing okay let's push
therefore i'm not sure about this at all
but we wants to grab stuff I didn't
think about that at all I can take you
five TG 5b should be to take t6 it's
this bad be surprising yeah and I saw
that but is it is it bad rock TX when
I'm a whole piece down and I'm a whole
look down then huh what did i do here
did I completely miss calendars probably
what what the earth what on earth did i
did i did i do here did i just miss
count that I guess I did right okay how
bad can you play I just completely
miscounted that I'm a look down here
okay what is he doing there he wants to
open up everything
Jeff it's it's a rock right but maybe in
check maybe I can still try to cause
some kind of some kind of mayhem nitey
form probably yes yes Queen a 3 shack
but what can you do e 2 probably does
the job
timelines unfortunately about everything
wins for him unfortunately
yeah it all it all losses
95 I have to check on b3 but is 25 year
now and that is really completely lost
checkmate you should always try to go
for a stupid stupid threat down
unbelievable yeah okay I know no comment
down I totally I totally miss counted
everything here I mean it's AB it's a
bit of a strange position and it's
probably somehow good for white but yeah
a force winning actually according to
the engine yeah so I shouldn't shouldn't
waste time there and resigns yeah
crashing crashing through one f6 here
okay yeah thought I can do this all in a
very slow ish fashion but it's not the
case yeah and now the extinct what did i
do that i just have to recap i mean this
is this is really really kind of weird
yeah why did I take on d6c I can I can
just take and and then it's a kind of a
position I don't know what it is yeah he
takes I take here and whatever i don't
know but this is just completely i just
totally miscounted yeah i'm a complete
route down yo check check computer's his
son mate yeah you can just take the
night of course i wanted i wanted to
check check I can always just interpose
he's up everything yeah this is
checkmate made in one yeah that's one of
the least deserving with victories ever
but
beep happens what can you do okay well
thanks for watching